Today we'll talk about another method of learning,
called learning by correcting mistakes. An agent reaches a decision.
The decision turns out to be incorrect, or sub optimal. Why did the agent make
that mistake? Can the agent correct its own knowledge and reasoning so
that it never makes that same mistake again? As an example, I'm driving and
I decide to change lanes. As I change lanes, I hear cars honking at me.
Clearly I made a mistake. But what knowledge, what reasoning led to
that mistake? Can I correct it, so that I don't make the mistake again?
Learning to correct mistakes is our first lesson in meta-reasoning.
We'll start today by revisiting explanation-based learning. Then we'll use
the explanations for isolating mistakes. This will be very similar diagnosis.
Except that here we'll be using explanation for isolating mistakes.
This will make it clear, why explanation is so central to knowledge based AI.
Then we'll talk about how we can use explanations for correcting mistakes which
will set up the foundation for subsequent discussion on metareasoning.